a Next Level delicious pastrami spice
salmon rye bread sandwich now there's a
mouthful
welcome to the next level kitchen where
we are taking your skills to the next
level by showing you great tips tricks
and delicious recipes yeah so now Gordon
there's there's something uh fishy in
the kitchen today but Richard please
keep to the cooking not the comedy today
we're going to be showing you one of our
favorite fish salmon and this is going
to go to the next level but before we
start cooking let me tell you what I do
with the tail of salmon you've got what
cut I'm going like top tier here I got
the center cut of salmon love that what
are you doing I'm gonna do very simple
like a salmon for four people like a
family feast nice I'm gonna do a
pastrami spice salmon sandwich finished
with almost like a sort of cream cheese
and a beautiful soft pickle I'm a native
New Yorker I feel like this is for me
Gordon uh it tells you know everyone
wants to tell them to Tata uh or they
know what to do with them so I'm going
to turn this thing into a beautiful
sandwich beautiful okay now first off
the tail
um so it's a little bit sort of unwanted
give it a nice season when I say said
earlier about the pastrami sort of
seasoning it's a mixture of Ginger
coriander and allspice with a little
touch of sugar in there so what that's
going to do is sort of almost get that
salmon nice and dark so it's like a sort
of
blackened salmon now these are the Tails
okay and this is a bit that it's thin
one end and thick the other so the best
way
to use these is inside that sandwich now
once that salmon is coated in that
pastrami spice okay let it sit there for
about a minute and let it sort of absorb
in to that salmon this is an oily fish
so as it starts to sit the oil comes out
and all those spices permeate
I love that it's taking me home it's
taking me home the Lower East Side of
New York let's go beautiful now what are
you doing Rich all right so like very
simple people get intimidated when
they're cooking seafood so I'm not even
gonna cook it in a pan people are
worried that the fish is going to stick
to the pan that they're not a pro so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna just take
this center cut this is for maybe two
three four people and I'm just gonna put
it in a oven proof baking dish and just
bake the dish it's that simple it's
going to go into the baking dish I have
salt I have pepper of course I'm going
to make sure that I'm gonna season both
sides I'm not going pastrami I'm just
going salt and pepper you could add
whatever spices you want and then to the
pan I'm gonna add all of my aromatics
and all of my flavors so lots of oil uh
we're almost making like a a sauce in
the pan with the salmon so layer the oil
bottom of the pan my salmon look at this
beautiful center cut fillet is going to
go right into my pan that's gonna pop
into the oven and then I'm going to load
onto the pan all of these amazing
aromatics so really I'm just I'm just
going to sort of layer some lemons on
here everyone knows that Citrus works
really really well lemon Works fantastic
with seafood I would say Gordon that
Citrus is like or vinegar or Citrus is
like the next level thing exactly that
also
ounce of salmon these lemon so I've
sliced my salmon now lengthway so I've
got that beautiful pastrami rub on the
outside
and when you're cooking salmon like this
the nice thing about it it Cooks so
quickly so I've got that nice spicy
texture on the outside the fish is oily
and what it does need okay is little
touch of lemon so before we use the
juice get that zest and zest that lemon
over that salmon and look you can see it
literally takes two minutes to cook this
salmon I love that you're using the zest
honestly and you will throw that away
exactly that turn these over
and look you can see how they're just
starting to sort of caramelize without
spice I'm going to roast that lemon zest
on there as well flip these little bits
of tail over and then from there
on the other side as well a touch more
love it now from there literally once
I've got
the sear in that pan turn off the gas
okay and just let it sit there it sits
and rests and marinated at the same time
that looks delicious I love it and
salmon is so forgiving right because
it's got so much fat and so much oil in
it I took some steamed potatoes I throw
that in the pan make sure every element
of your dish is seasoned salt pepper on
the potatoes look at the Salmon it's
buried in all of these herbs and lemon
I'm gonna pop that into the oven it's
gonna cook for 20 or 25 minutes and then
that is going to be done
uh real quick fast forward 25 minutes
and there it is my salmon cooked just
baked you don't have to cook it in a pan
maybe you're not that skilled this is
the way to do it and then I have these
beautiful potatoes I'm going to make a
ranch dressing horseradish sauce with
wow you love that ranch dressing what is
it with you in ranch I just love ranch
dressing
enough respect if I said butter meal
do you have more respect for it I would
you would exactly so call it buttermilk
dressing horseradish and salmon a
classic combination it kind of works
with the pastrami flavors that you have
over there big time so how do I lift up
the acidity in this sandwich
um it's called a quick pickle I've got
some water some salt some sugar some
beautiful white wine vinegar a red onion
coriander seeds
peppercorns and this a little bay leaf
bring that up to the boil
again quick picking and just let it sit
there and soak soak
let's work this out salmon sat in its
oil without pastrami seasoning we've got
the quick pickling and this other layers
that bring this sandwich together this
is rye bread Okay so
how do we get that rye bread packed with
even more flavor Touch of olive oil into
your pan and I'm going to do now is just
toast let's talk about that crisp
texture on the outside that nice oily
beautiful flavor in the center lightly
season the pan first which then helps to
season the bread and then literally get
your rye bread in and just get that
sizzling in the pan now check out that
salmon honestly
let's have a look at that there ready to
have a little touch looking good it's
spicy it's delicious I'm loving it again
because it's got so much fat in it for
the home cook it's it's an easier fish
perhaps to cook it's so good so good
love this finishing up my sauce over
here I'm throwing mayonnaise in with all
of these dried herbs some chives some
dill a little bit of Buttermilk as well
that's going to give it another layer of
acidity and then I'm just going to toss
This Together uh and then I'm gonna toss
my potatoes in my homemade Horseradish
ranch dressing and of course I can't
forget if it's horseradish ranch
dressing to add the horseradish nice and
spicy and we have these spicy acidic
flavors that are going to work
wonderfully with this fatty Rich fish
love it love it now this is where our
sandwich goes to the next level the top
tier rye bread nice and crispy okay but
before I start putting the salmon and
the onions on there
peaceful cream cheese okay a classic
especially when it comes
with the salmon spread that on
generously okay you can see it's just
starting to melt nothing wrong with that
whatsoever from there I'm gonna spread
it on both sides think about it it's
salmon cream cheese Rye fresh dill okay
just lightly
sprinkle the top of that rye bread with
that fragrant Dill now you can see how
we're building in those Next Level
flavors
from there there was a zest again
onto the sandwich that's right literally
now we've got the zest off the lemon
okay there's another part the juice
watch for that someone comes out the pan
you just sprinkle that lemon over the
salmon and now
for the magic moment okay I'm gonna take
my nice long
layers of salmon one
two
let's go for the small one here three
over
sit there on top then
take those beautiful quick pickled
onions
sit that on top
and look Richard even before we close
that baby up you can just see how
delicious that is not only that
delicious look how colorful yeah you got
the acidity the red and the orange and
the white right there and then look
that beautiful toasted rye bread sits on
top there
I'm just gonna literally I've got to cut
this because I'm obsessed with this
sandwich in
and then literally lift that up
and that
amazing beautiful
salmon pastrami rye bread sandwich
and then just hit that and it will touch
of green and these little pickles are
going to be on the side just
literally bite and pick bite and pick
and then we have a Next Level delicious
pastrami spice salmon rye bread sandwich
now there's a mouthful there it is
Gordon I'm finishing it up over here I
have my potatoes tossed in that homemade
uh ranch dressing a little bit of
pickled beets we've just flaked the
salmon off of the larger piece and there
it is look at that sandwich look at that
fun little plate there he's hungry again
let's go
[Music]
that's how you take and elevate your
dish to the next level now to get the
ingredients and more details on today's
recipes check out the description below
and be sure to subscribe for more
amazing recipes from this genius and
this genius too well done